burns are skin injuries caused by heat
chemicals electricity or radiation
doctor will recommend treatment based on
the size of your burn and the layers of
skin the burn effects your skin has
three main layers the epidermis the
dermis and the hypodermis or
subcutaneous layer containing fat blood
vessels and nerves beneath the skin are
tissues such as muscle fasciae and bone
first degree or superficial burns affect
only your epidermis the burn site
appears red and dry with no blisters and
is mildly painful
second degree or partial-thickness burns
involve your epidermis and portions of
your upper dermis and lower dermis the
burn site is red and moist and may be
blistered swollen and very painful
third degree or full thickness burns
extend through your dermis and into the
hypodermis the burn site appears patchy
in color ranging from white to brown
with a dry leathery texture because the
burn is so deep it causes little or no
pain
fourth-degree burns involve the
destruction of all layers of your skin
sometimes extending into the underlying
muscle or bone these burns are brown dry
charred and almost always painless
you can treat your first-degree burn by
soaking it in cool water for a few
minutes to soothe and protect the tissue
apply an antibiotic ointment and cover
with a clean dry bandage you can take
acetaminophen or ibuprofen for pain here
for a second-degree burn by soaking in
cool water for several minutes apply an
antibiotic ointment to prevent infection
and cover with a clean dry non stick
bandage change your bandage every day
and make sure your hands are clean
acetaminophen or ibuprofen may help with
pain and swelling
if you have a third or fourth degree
burn go immediately to an emergency
department if you can elevate the burned
body part higher than your heart
you will also need to seek medical
attention if your burn is larger than
three inches in diameter or if it is
located on your face hands feet groin
buttocks or over a major joint